- Welcome to tonight's panel discussion
election 2020, what
happened and what's next?
I am Alan Gerber.
I'm the Director of the
Institution for Social and Policy Studies
and Professor of Political Science.
and I'm gonna be serving as
the moderator of tonight's event.
ISPS is the sponsor of tonight's event.
ISPS is a University Research Center
advancing disciplinary and
interdisciplinary research
in the social sciences
to understand our society
and inform scholarly debate,
democratic deliberation and public policy.
The format for tonight's event will be
first comments from each of the panelists.
They're gonna talk for five minutes or so.
Following their initial comments,
we're gonna be having a panel discussion
of maybe 15 or 20 minutes.
We'll see how much time we have for that.
And then we wanna leave a half an hour
for question and answer session
from answering questions
from the participants.
Let me describe some of
the logistics of that.
Please send questions
throughout the presentations
using the Q&A button on the
bottom of the Zoom screen.
Tonight's event is being recorded.
If you need technical assistance,
please email ISPS@yale.edu.
We're gonna be monitoring that
in case you have some
technical difficulties
we can help you with.
Tonight's panelists in
order of appearance,
the way we're gonna do
this as I'm gonna introduce
all five of our distinguished panelists
and then they're gonna just talk in order.
So in order of appearance,
tonight's outstanding panel panelists.
First, we'll be hearing from Jacob Hacker.
Jacob is the Stanley Reser
Professor of Political Science
and he was the Director of
ISPS from 2011 until 2020.
So he was the director right before me
and I still have a lot
to learn from Jacob.
Jacob is a member
of the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences,
the National Academy of Social Insurance
and the recipient of numerous
awards for his scholarship.
He's especially known for his writings
on American politics and public policy.
And he is an expert on healthcare policy
and he's one of the originators
and developers of the public option
which is really a critical
part of the policy debate
on healthcare in the United States.
He's the author of numerous books
including a work with his
coauthor, Paul Pierson.
And I see right behind
Jacob's right shoulder
from his perspective and I
guess left shoulder from ours
is his most recent book,
"Let Them Eat Tweets."
and so you can help make
that book a bestseller.
Our second speaker tonight
will be Christina Kinane.
Professor Kinane is an Assistant Professor
of Political Science at
Yale and a research fellow
at the Institution for
Social and Policy Studies.
Professor Kinane studies
the executive branch
and political control of the bureaucracy
including the role of
legislatures, executives
and the bureaucracy in policymaking.
Professor Kinane is working
on a book (indistinct)
entitled "Vacancy Politics
Presidential Appointments,
"and the Strategic
Evasion of Senate Consent"
which investigates how presidents
strategically use vacancies
to promote their policy priorities.
Next we'll hear from Isabela Mares,
the Arnold Wolfers Professor
of Political Science.
Mares studies a range of
topics in comparative politics
and political economy,
including democratization,
clients wisdom and corruption, taxation,
and fiscal capacity development
and social policy reforms
in both developed and
developing countries.
Her recent book co-authored
with Lauren Young
is "Conditionality and
Coercion Electoral Clientelism
"in Eastern Europe."
And that book won
the American Political
Science Associations,
extremely prominent and eminent Award,
The William Wright Kerr Award
for best book in political economy.
So we'll hear from Isabela.
After Isabela, we get David Mayhew,
again, we're going in alphabetical order.
David Mayhew is Sterling Professor
Emeritus of Political Science,
a fellow of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences,
the American Philosophical Society
and the National Academy of Sciences.
That's the trifecta, I think,
in the social sciences.
So congratulations to David.
David is a renowned scholar
of American politics
an expert on pretty much everything.
He's the author of perhaps
the most influential book
on Congress of the last 50 years,
"Congress, the Electoral Connection."
He has a lot of other books,
every one of them is well worth reading.
"America's Congress" is in
a really nice one, 2000.
I really liked that one and
then "Divided We Govern"
may or may not be the book to turn to
depending how it will go in January.
And finally, we'll be
hearing from Saad Omer.
Professor Omer is a specialist
in infectious diseases
and vaccination policy.
In 2020, I don't know that
there's any post-election panel
that can be formed
without having an expert
on infectious diseases.
Like Saad as part of the discussion
because of the extraordinary importance
of our public health
policy over the last year
and in the coming year.
Professor Omer is a professor of medicine
at the Yale School of Medicine
and the Susan Dwight Bliss,
Professor of Epidemiology
at the Yale School of Public Health.
He's a fellow, oh, excuse me,
he's the director of the Yale
Institute for Global Health
and a fellow of the Infectious
Diseases Society of America
winner of awards for his scholarship
on the impact of immunizations.
He conducts research on interventions
to increase immunization
coverage and acceptance.
Again incredibly critical
public policy issue
in the coming months.
Professor Omer served
as an academic affiliate
of the White House Social
and Behavioral Sciences team
under, I guess it was Barack Obama
and he is on the advisory panels
for the important vaccination bench
trying to understand what
policies need to be set
regarding the vaccination
approvals and distribution.
He is on both the United
States Advisory Panel
for the vaccines, as
well as the WHO Panel.
So he is a real expert on this
incredibly important public policy issue.
Welcome to all of our panelists.
One last thing before we turn it over
to these distinguished panelists,
if you enjoy today's event, there's more.
We're having another event
December the 1st at 7:30 to 8:45.
Tonight's panelists and our discussion
will be focused to some
extent a bit more on
the macro picture public
policy of governance.
On the 1st of December,
we have more of a political
behavior heavy panel.
So if you wanna know things
about what the voters did
and why did they do it,
you'll get some of that
tonight, I would imagine.
But you'll get a lot of
it on December 1st at 7:30
for that panel, we'll be having
Alex Coppock and Josh Kalla
from the Yale Political
Science Department,
two political behavior scholars
as well as Mike Podhorzer
who is the assistant
to the president of the
AFL-CIO for strategic research.
Mike is a incredible
expert on the nitty gritty
of the American voter and
American political behavior
especially contemporary
American political behavior.
We'll also be having Lynn Vavreck
who has been conducting
a tremendous amount
of survey research during the campaign.
And she's an expert on
presidential elections
and campaign effects in
presidential elections.
So if you're interested in that angle,
the political behavior angle
on December 1st at 7:30,
please look out for the ISPS events,
what did voters do and why did they do it.
With that, let me turn
it over to our panelists
who will speak without any
intervening interruption
in alphabetical order.
So please kick us off Jacob.
- Great (indistinct).
Thanks so much, Alan,
thanks to Lamar Pier
and Pam Greene for doing
the backside tech and
preparation for this event.
And thanks to this amazing
group of panelists.
It's a real pleasure to be with you.
I also appreciate Alan's
mentioning the book,
I see we have about 245 attendees
so you could double my book sales
if you all went on and bought the book.
Well, I think we all should celebrate.
It's now official.
Charles Koch has said that
the winner is Joe Biden.
So we should just all be clapping.
For those who didn't read the interview
with the elder Koch brother,
the surviving of the
two that are associated
with conservative political causes.
He also went on to say
that he was really sorry that he messed up
American politics with all his investments
to which the Twitterati responded
with a mix of humor and contempt.
Here's my favorite, he said
something to the effect of
we really screwed things
up is what Koch said.
This is the response.
You can screw up a cookie recipe,
you can screw up parallel parking,
those things can be
shrugged off and repaired.
You can't screw up a
country, its elections,
its media landscape, a
major political party
and just say, oops, my bad.
So I wanna talk a little bit about
that major political party because
I think we should first recognize
that the electoral defeat
of a would be authoritarian
is a very big deal.
I think Joe Biden would add
another word to the description
between big and deal but this
is a major accomplishment,
but I think as Paul and I'd argue,
Paul Pierson and I argued in our book,
"Let Them Eat Tweets,"
which begins with the line
this is not a book about Donald Trump.
Donald Trump is not the sole reason
as Charles Koch's comments suggest
that our democracy has not been working
as well as it could or should.
And I think the election
delivered a kind of split verdict
on the future of American democracy.
On the one hand, as I said,
would be authoritarians are
rarely defeated at the polls
and democratic backsliding
as the comparative college
could've continued much more quickly
had Donald Trump been reelected.
But at the same time,
the fact that Republicans
actually gained seats in the house
may well hold on to the Senate
And it seems like the more likely outcome,
I'm sure David will give us
examples of every runoff race
in the history of the United States
to analyze the prospects.
But it seems likely that
Republicans will hold the Senate
and thus that Mitch McConnell
will be the majority leader.
And that is obviously gonna mean that
the president elect's ability
to achieve many of the goals
he set out during the
campaign will be limited.
It also means, and I think
this is really important
to understand is that
the pressure is on the Republican
party to change course.
They're gonna be less than
they might've been otherwise.
Back in the late, well
actually the early 2010s,
Barack Obama famously asked
whether the GOP fever will break
and that fever unfortunately
still seems to be raging.
The other thing I wanna just mention
and I think we should talk about tonight
is the extent to which this
party that has been radicalized
over the last generation has
managed to insulate itself
from electoral
accountability in many ways.
The fact is that
Republicans have brode into
America's counter
majoritarian institution.
They hold their appointees
hold a decisive majority
on the Supreme Court and lower courts.
It's a notable fact
that the 63 majority
on the Supreme Court is
a good chunk of the
people who constitute it
were either or both
appointed by a president
who did not win the popular vote
or confirmed by a Senate majority
that did not represent
a majority of Americans.
And we know that the Senate
is heavily tilted towards rural America
and that rural America is heavily tilted
toward the Republican party.
And we also know that
the Electoral College
has become a much advantageous
terrain for the Republicans.
So there's a variety of
reasons why Republicans
are under less pressure to moderate
even though the most extreme instantiation
of the Republican retreat
from the center Donald Trump was defeated.
So I'll just close in my last few minutes
by mentioning what I
consider to be the kind of
a half full or half empty version
of our democratic glass right now.
So on the one hand, as I said,
I think we've seen a clear
rebuke to a president who
has continued to flout democratic
norms and who, as I said,
represented a clear and present danger
to American democracy.
On, the other hand, the fact
that we have Republican silence
or worse in the face of a failed president
continuing to do legitimated elections
is an extremely worrisome
sign that we're going to see
continuing intense fights
over the future of American
democracy and American politics.
The base of the Republican
party is thoroughly Trumpian.
The structures of organized outrage
that have supported him remain in place.
Indeed Fox News now looks
like a moderate alternative
to other sources of
information for conservatives.
And finally we know from history that
obstruction has paid off
for the Republican party.
Mitch McConnell, once again
will be in the position of
deciding what is possible for an incoming
democratic administration.
And will almost certainly say,
as he did back under President Obama
that his top priority is to
make the democratic incumbent
a one-term president.
How will it end up, let's stay tuned
and let's discuss it tonight.
- Okay well thank you Jacob.
And thank you, Alan and Pam and Omer
for all of your organization efforts.
I am thrilled to be here
to be a part of this
incredibly amazing panel
and to kind of discuss and digest
a bit of what we've
experienced politically
for the last year of the election,
for the last four years of
this current administration
to kind of look forward.
The topic of this panel being
what happened and what's next.
Jacob, you lead us off with
such a wonderful set of thoughts
on how we might consider moving forward
with the Republican party as it is.
I'd like to add a little bit
of my own flavor to that mix
and think through or at
least start the conversation
on one of the pillars of the
Biden campaign really ran on
which was the administration's handling
or some might say mishandling
of the COVID-19 epidemic.
And what that really
shines a bright light on
is the in which the administration
has handled appointments
to the federal bureaucracy
and the way that the
administration has ran and managed
our governments or
mismanaged as some might say.
And particularly thinking
through exactly what happened
in the last four years,
the Trump administration is leaving us
with a federal government
that is led by mostly
acting officials in these oftentimes are
or not oftentimes rather,
almost entirely not vetted by the Senate.
They're not confirmed by the Senate,
they're filling those positions
on an interim capacity.
But under the Federal
Vacancies Reform Act,
they're only supposed to serve
for a limited amount of time
and Trump is exceedingly
either just blown past those deadlines
or submitted nominees to a Senate who
as Jacob so nicely put
is run by Republicans
and you would think would
then confirm his appointees
that aren't, they aren't
confirming his appointees.
This leaves these actings
in those positions.
We've seen a variety of things come down
where those actings are
potentially not legal,
the decisions that they make
are not legal most recently
with acting Secretary of
Homeland Security, Chad Wolf.
And the question this brings
is what the Biden administration can do
in the process of transitioning.
When you transition to
a new administration,
you're reliance on the individuals
who are filling the
positions at this time.
And oftentimes in that transition,
you'll see the top
cabinet positions set off
and the deputy secretaries
takeover for short amount of time
to kind of fill the gaps as an acting.
But when you have acting
deputy secretaries
or you have vacancies
in those acting deputy
secretary positions,
so that someone can move up
into the acting secretary position itself.
This calls into question
exactly how the Biden administration
is gonna get their feet under them
and get off onto a good start.
And really when our conversation
turns to what's next,
that's what we have to
start thinking about
with the Biden administration
transitioning out of this election
and thinking about the
hurdles that already exist
to a new administration.
You have 1200 presidential appointments
that require Senate
confirmation to be filled.
Now we can have a
conversation at a later time
as to whether or not that is necessary.
The politicization of the
federal government certainly
is questionable for a lot
and has been a subject
of research for political scientists.
But when we think as to what Biden's
gonna be able to achieve
as Jacob mentioned,
he's going to need to
rely on those appointees.
And if he is stymied by the
Senate in terms of confirmation,
Trump has really laid out
there almost a playbook
for pursuing his own
strategies of appointments
outside of the Senate.
So I'm excited to kind of think
through what means as well
with the rest of the panelists, thank you.
- Okay, thank you so much to Alan
for inviting me to be part of this panel
and to Pam and Omer for organizing.
So, as Alan mentioned, I am
studying comparative politics.
And so this identity
in fact helps me today
because quite honestly,
there's so much about
the 2020 elections that
I don't understand.
Okay (laughs).
So at the time Alan has asked me
to be part of this round table,
I wouldn't have anticipated
that we would be today
nearly two weeks after the election
in this ambiguous situation,
which is a slow motion.
So the outgoing president
has not yet recognized
the legitimacy of the election
nor has he yet considered defeat.
While perhaps this is
unsurprising for Donald Trump,
what is more worrying
about democratic erosion
is that the Republican party
is complicit with the strategy.
Nearly half of the political
class elected to the Senate
and to the house today are
complicit in a strategy
to delegitimize a democratically
elected president.
Yesterday, The Washington Post
reported based on interviews
of the Georgia secretary of state
that Senator Lindsey Graham
tried to pressure him
that the Georgia Secretary of State
to find ways to exclude legal balance.
So how does this moment in time,
how does this unprecedented
democratic fragility
of the United States fit
in the democratic landscape
of eroding democracies?
So I want to draw
attention to the fact that
if we look in a comparative setting,
the situation in the
United States is bleak.
So hearing about this episode yesterday,
I was reminded about Nancy
Bermeo's in very important book
"Ordinary People In Extraordinary Times".
I don't know how many of you here
are familiar with this
study but to my knowledge,
this is the best account
of democratic erosion
we have in comparative politics.
This is a study of 18 countries
that experienced democratic breakdown
in Europe and Latin America
during the interwar period
in the '60s and '70s.
Bermeo asks the simple question.
What distinguishes cases
that remain democracies
from cases where democracy
ultimately caught that.
Her main result is highly relevant
for the situation of
the United States today.
The studies on the
importance of elite behavior
and on a variable that Bermeo
calls distancing capacity.
She defines distancing capacity
as the ability of members
of the incumbent party
to distance themselves from the behavior,
from the lawless behavior
of their co-partizan allies
end of the quote.
So evidence of such distancing capacity
comes in the form of
condemnation of lawlessness
of the prosecution.
This was present in Finland
and the Czech Republic
and then over a period and
this was where these members
of the dominant sanction violence
or transgressions of democratic norms,
but was absent in countries that
sort of right where democracy collapsed.
So what is remarkable about
the United States today
in broad comparison to
these historical cases
is that it takes extremely low measures
on the variable measuring
distancing capacity.
Moreover, I cannot see a
way how distancing capacity
can be established within
the Republican party.
Who the actors of change
are and what sanctions
they may have at their disposal
to enforce this behavior
among their co-partisans.
So at this critical historical juncture,
Republicans are complicit
with Trump's decision
to deny the legitimacy of the election,
just to increase their bargaining power
with a new president.
So this is my view creates
a very somber scenario
for the Biden's presidency
who would have to devote
considerable energy
to fight off accusation of illegitimacy
in the eyes of sort of
about 30% of the voters.
So the future in my view is oblique.
So turning on to the elections,
I have sort of one or two kind of thoughts
about the outcome of the election
and they have to do with the
nature of popular appeals
The elections have build
a very ambiguous results
that I find quite difficult to understand.
So even though President
Trump lost the election,
over 70 million voters voted for him.
This can see in the middle
of a precedent pandemic
and the disastrous response
of the federal government
to this public health crisis.
So this is really positive
for most explanations
in political science that highlight
the ability of voters to
sanction bad politicians
especially in moments of economic crisis.
At the same time, the election has yielded
very ambiguous results for Democrats.
Even if President Biden
won the popular vote,
the election has not been successful
by the most Democratic
candidates on ballot.
The Democratic majority
in the house has shrunk
and no Democrat competing in
Red States has been reelected.
So what explanations do we
have in political science
to make sense of these results?
This suggests to me
that we have really not fully appreciated
the power and strength
of populist appears.
So what do I mean by populist?
So even though we have
experienced four years
of a populist president,
it's quite hard to explain what they do.
They govern through provocation,
they govern through the creation of enemy,
the fake media, the quote
unquote rapist migrants,
the quote unquote Chinese virus.
What populists do is that
they introduce in a policy
this course, a new dimension
that this orthogonal
to the existing policy dimension.
And so they govern by flaming up
the structuring of opposition they need.
And so this is what we
call in political science,
(indistinct) sort of strategies.
So we don't have a good explanation
of how these messages work
and we often dismiss them
as being kind of theatrical of a populist.
But I think we don't fully understand how
this populist rhetoric was successful
to maintain the electoral
coalition of Trump
in the face of the dramatic
economic shock of the pandemic.
So let me again turn
into the pandemic, right?
How did Trump respond to the pandemic?
Like other populists around the world,
he had two strategies,
anti-scientists, deny the
existence of the virus
and sort of the anti-foreign strategies
blaming foreign countries
such as China on the virus.
So to understand sort of
like how these messages
sort of might have helped
him maintain support
among sort of like his 70 million voters
which I mentioned above,
It's important to think about sort of like
the two effects of sort of like populism.
One is that this orthogonal dimension
of political competition creates
a really difficult choice
for other parties, whether or
not to engage with this issue
should the Democrats have responded
to all this nonsense about
Chinese origin of the virus?
But I do think the more
important consequence
of these messages is that
they have spill over effects
on the main access of
political competition,
the left-right dimension.
So in other words, what
populous messages do
is that they depress
the support for policy
or the demand for policy
even among the groups
that are very severely hurt such as voters
who have experienced COVID
or have experienced downturn.
And we have lots of surveys
evidence that I have collected
with colleagues during the pandemic
sort of by documenting this.
That calling sort of rights...
If you exposed to voters to these messages
of the virus is a hoax,
that in fact depresses their demand
for a policy voters that have
experienced an income shock.
So I do think this is sort of right part
of the explanation of the the spousal
why Trump was able to maintain
electoral coalition intact
during a pandemic without
providing any policy response
and by engaging in thin
populist messages only.
This is what Barry
Weingast has called also
the tragic brilliance of the populist.
And I think kind of this sort of populism
explains another sort of positive outcome
of the election, which is
the growing educational
and geographic polarization
of the electorate.
So voters without college education
appear to have resonated most strongly
to these anti-elitism
messages and sort of write
and by tapping into this
anti-elite resentment,
these messages have undermined
the support of these voters
for a distributed policies
such as college credit
or Medicare for all
advocated by the candidates.
So I would add all these comments,
I'm just suggesting that sort
of we as political scientists
have a sort of a deeper
obligation to really understand
sort of like the importance
of these messages
in creating this hub is
very paradoxical results
that we have seen in this election.
- Okay.
Well, thanks for inviting me, Alan.
I'm gonna say quickly what
happened and what's next
which was what we're supposed to do.
What happened?
I think the election as
a considerable victory
for moderation and probably
for coalition government
over the American sword.
I think the favor is down
that is with Trump dispatched
and the left pretty much
staved off, the favor is down.
That is the menace that each
side seasoned the other side
is substantially diminished
on both on both sides.
The Democrats gained the
presidency and the vice presidency
by a considerable property
of majority as it happens
and net one Senate seat.
Republicans gained something
like 10 house seats
and one governorship and two
State Legislative Chambers
and conservatives had
some notable victories
in the referendum profits processes.
And a lot of ways, it's the
standoff though of course
the presidency is a big
prize and now by to gets it
with a substantial popular edge.
I think the coalitions,
this year voter coalitions
are basically a continuation
of ones that we've seen for
20 years or so and an evolution of them.
We've been evolving into
a kind of class cleavage
between diploma people that
is a college diploma people
and non-diploma people.
It is a cleavage that
would have surprised marks
but there it is.
You'd have to rewrite the whole business
but it looks like a class cleavage.
It's a cleavage of interests
that are preferences and of
attitudes that I don't think
political science studies
particularly well.
I think the election was nicely conducted.
It's a great success.
There was a lot of previews
to say preview and saying,
there's gonna be a terrible mess.
And even though some folks came in late,
we knew that was gonna happen.
It's ordinary processes and a
little extraordinary this year
because of COVID but quite defensible
and I think properly handled processes.
There seems to be no
fraud and little disorder.
It's a disorder here and
there that could be ignored.
Trump's denial is not going anywhere.
and it seems to be a
kind of closing tantrum
that he's engaged again that may go on
for another week or so.
It won't go anywhere, it
doesn't have anything to do
with who holds the office.
The complaints will go on
that they election was unfair,
this is somewhat a different matter
difference in whether it can be overturned
on the evidence unfair.
But we're saying that before,
in fact we saw it after the 2016 election
it's unfair, it was Russia and all that.
It's a page out of Andrew Jackson.
Remember him with the
tragic for four years
was a corrupt bargain?
Was it didn't effect?
It was John Quincy
Adams at the white house
during those four years.
We're not getting
resistance in the streets.
Last time as the way we did last year
after the 2016 election.
All in all, as I say, I
think the favor is down
as the victory for moderation.
I think maybe the democracy is dying.
Scripts should be put
back in the file cabinet.
That's the, what happened?
Now the what next?
I think one main effect event going on
at the governing is that
there'll be more day-to-day
and week-to-week stability
in the white house.
That is not a minor thing.
That's firing people,
expostulation, changes, erraticness.
That's gonna go away.
It's a good thing it
goes away particularly
probably for the conduct
of foreign policy.
I think the governing Biden...
President Biden can do a great deal
with executive directives
and we'll see that
in the fashion of Obama and Trump
There's kind of a pink box
category character to that,
one president does something,
the next president takes it back.
Then the next president may do it again
but it's important and some of it sticks.
So we'll see executive
orders of some importance and
that this presidents come and
got to do something in a hurry
as Trump did early on and that will be
the sort of what Biden does in hurry.
climate change I'll go back
to the comparison courts
sooner or later.
The pipeline came down
from Canada won't be built,
the business regulations will
be taken way they'll be doing,
immigration and so forth.
But there'll be a lot of
ruling by Zoroastrian diktat
from the White House and the
bureaucracy that will be there.
But there are limits to
executive orders that are not,
executive orders and
not executive directives
were generally are not
embedded in statutes.
And so they're perishable
as Trump's as we'll find out
some of the Trumps are.
And of courts are out there.
The courts are probably
got to go to bulk up
and their policing of your credit diktats
given the doctorates that are in the heads
of some of those injustices.
So there we are.
I think on Capitol Hill, we're
gonna have narrow majorities,
whatever else happens, a narrow
majority in Senate or none.
A narrow majority in the house.
It looks like formal divided party control
which is after all normal
in American politics,
70% of the time since 1980,
it's the normal way of governing.
We can't be sure it will be
formally divided party control
because we now know about Georgia.
Georgia down there,
we got up those two
Republican seats hanging
and there it is.
It's I don't know what's gonna happen
and I'm not holding my breath
for the Democrats to
take both of those seats.
It's difficult the track run,
as somebody mentioned I was
talking about this track record
of runoffs in Georgia
has been pretty favorable
for the Republicans
and I see the dumping
get an awful lot of money
in publicity.
Who knows, we just don't know.
A lot of that depends on what happens
during the next eight weeks after all.
Elections are to some degree
reactions to what happened
because six weeks before those elections
for the election that's held in Georgia.
Another thing that will
happen on Capitol Hill,
with divided party control is
dependent on the Georgia seats
but there's Joe Manchin there anyway.
Even if the Democrats pick up
those those two Georgia seats
and probably Joe Manchin,
the Conservative Democrat
from West Virginia becomes
the pivottable Senator
on some matters.
So is already going on and
say it's taking some positions
that the party doesn't like.
Also on Capitol Hill and there is,
the Democrats in the
house are having trouble
arraying themselves and
picking a leader they may have.
I think Nancy Pelosi is gonna get restored
as speaker though she's
gonna have to fight for it
from every last person.
There are a majorities
are narrow on both sides
and the Democrats in the house looked like
something like 223 to
212, something like that.
It's there.
In Georgia...
Yeah, so we'll just say...
I already said that it
looks like (mumbles)
faction and stuff that
is fierce scrapping.
Some of it has come out into the press
during the last week or two
between the progressive faction
and the moderate faction and so on
which makes it very
hard to run that party.
But I don't wanna say this, I means,
there's a tendency to blame
the leadership at Congress
if there is, because they
can hurt the cat sometimes
some of that but
we should realize that
the factions within
parties on Capitol Hill
are very common in American history
and deemed possibly normal
that as sometimes they're
not so easy to see
as what the tea party
faction which didn't show up
with a roll call voting
because the party leaders
could at least arrange
what has been voted out in the floor
to minimize their apparent,
to minimize their real factionalism.
So it's a tough job that
state policy has got.
but we should realize that
we shouldn't blame her
or blame the democratic party
if they're killing each other.
It's in some of them way there,
I think some of those people
who like to kill each other right now
are among the house Democrats
the way they're talking we'll see.
But factions in Congress are
an extrusion from the society
and a normal extrusion from the society.
So let's not blame the
party or the leaders.
Honestly Capitol Hill
and some of the Democrats
ambitious legislative program
it's not gonna happen,
almost certainly not gonna happen
throughout the next couple of years
or probably the next four
years, given the numbers.
And certainly there's a list of things
that probably won't happen.
They won't have a police reform
the way the Democrats would like it.
There'll be no agreement deal.
There'll be no ban on fracking.
There'll be no Medicare for all.
There'll be no public option.
It looks like there'll
be no $15 minimum wage
There'll be no ban on right to work laws.
There'll be no contract unionization.
They had a long platform you know.
Some of this is platform
and some of it is just
the sort of stuff that parties
wanted to do for sometime
when they get a chance.
There'll be no lecture reform.
There'll be no big tax hikes.
There'll be no card packing
and decided that's not gonna go
and then they're not gonna
get rid of the syllabus story,
or even tamper with the syllabus, right?
I thought two or three weeks ago
that the Democrats are gonna
have enough for charity
in the setup.
So the filibuster at least
cook a lot with the life
out of it, but that's not
gonna happen right now.
Joe Manchin says, no, they can't touch it.
All this is not gonna happen.
If Joe Manchin of the Democrat
does become the pivottable
member then some of this altars
that Joe Manchin apparently
is open to some tax take backs
and tax coalition
backing which apparently,
the Democrats might be
able to flip through
through reconciliation in a 50/50 Senate
that includes (mumbles).
That's there but other stuff,
it's not clear that the Manchin question
would make a difference.
Be aware of though that ashes to ashes
that is a personnel change.
There's some important changes
the coalitions of the Congress have made
because people die and retire
as Teddy Kennedy back tragically in 2010,
do you remember that?
And in the past people
defecting or people dying
or people retiring, people
going into the cabinet
have affected the coalition
control on Capitol Hill
or close to it.
So we can anyway, there's no crystal ball
that can take us into that one.
Then I would say finally
that without this program,
without an ambitious legislative
program, I don't know.
I think with Biden's presidency,
there's not so much space
for hot button for...
Is my picture up there,
it's at the top, right?
- David, know you're absolutely.
Your picture is perfect.
You're coming up to about 10 minutes
and you'll have an opportunity to
amplify on some of these themes
during the question and
answer and panel discussion.
Is there a final thought
you'd like to leave us with
before we move on?
- Biden has got a tough presidency.
It's got to be an inbox
and management presidency
like Harry Truman's not a
legislative program presidency.
It's a very tough four years coming up.
- Sure, terrific.
Thank you.
Saad Omer.
- So hi.
You might be wondering what an
epidemiologist is doing here
and there's one explanation.
Since everyone went home on March 15th,
there's an oversupply of
armchair epidemiologists.
so maybe I'm taking
revenge on other fields
by becoming an armchair
political scientist
in this post election season
now, but that's not the reason.
The reason I'm here is because of
this pandemic response in
the US has been a failure.
There's no other way to describe it.
Those of us who have been
working on infectious diseases
including pandemic preparedness,
my first interaction and
my first serious effort
was actually around
2006 when H5N1 influenza
was a risk and so on and so forth
and was engaged with
some work around H1N1.
And a lot of people had expected that
there could be a virus
which would impact the US in
the way it is impacting us now
which would lead to
deaths even more deaths
or could lead to deaths in higher numbers.
But no serious scholar had
imagined and I've asked around.
I have asked people that if we were...
We always thought if you were this bad
in terms of mortality and morbidity,
not necessarily spread but
specifically mortality,
there will be a hundred other
countries worse than us.
And there was a for example,
the latest global health security index
ranked which came out in 2019
ranks the US as number one.
And obviously we are not number one
at least not in a positive sense.
And the reason why I'm here is that
it's not a failure of science.
We have had PCR and antigen tests
and social distancing
and masks and vaccines
although these are
newer types of vaccines,
but the overall vaccine
approach for decades.
What failed wasn't science,
what failed was governance.
And in Public Health,
if I want to prepare
for the next pandemic,
I can't do that without an approach
that involves a serious mature
hard-nosed look at governance
and governance you know, it is sad.
I know, I'm sure a lot
of you are aware that
democracies don't have famines.
I'm paraphrasing someone obviously.
But democracies have pandemics and
democracies make a mess it
seems of pandemic response.
So that's the reason why
we need to discuss this.
That's why institutions are important.
That's why appointments are important.
That's why prominence of career folks
and political appointees in decisions
and random radiologists
from Stanford is important.
And so one of the things going
forward would be important
is trust in institutions.
And part of my work is
focused on vaccine acceptance
and trust in vaccines.
And a lot of people that you
have seen different services,
when we looked at it, it was in may.
We found only 67% would
sort of right away accept the vaccine.
The rates for two other
service pure and others
have actually gone down
of our current acceptance.
And these are not your run of
the mild anti-vaccine folks.
There's a huge chunk of folks
who are suspicious of the process,
who saw what happened
with hydroxychloroquine,
with convalescent plasma
where there was perhaps a reason
to issue emergency authorization.
And you could argue have a
good faith argument about
the merits or demerits of that.
But the way it was projected,
the way first politicized
freaked a lot of people out.
And since then, there has been
a cost correction at the FDA
due to pushback of the career folks
but also due to pushback
of the political appointees
at the FDA as well but the
general public doesn't know.
And so therefore we need to...
The fact that I'm seeing
this huge gap in the response
in terms of serious investment
in vaccine confidence
and serious investments
in a national education
and communication campaign.
Public Health has...
This is not the first time
there has been a Public Health response.
But whenever we have had a major national
or international level response,
we've had an evidence-based
education and communications campaign.
And a communications
campaign is not run through
press conferences or tweets exclusively.
Social media is obviously
a part of all of this stuff
but it has to be coherent and it has to be
reasonably evidence-based.
And so I'll share a piece
of data that we generated
in collaboration with Alan and Greg Huber
and a really talented postdoc
from political science, Scott Bootcamper
where we had these survey experiments
where we found that even if
you had approval of the vaccine
a week before the election
versus in December,
there would be a much higher acceptance
and confidence in vaccine if
it were approved in December.
And then we did this survey experiment
way before the election, several
weeks before the election.
And so that is reassuring.
We also found that elite
endorsement by a Dr. Fauci,
by Tony Fauci
but also bipartisan
endorsement could move people.
So that kind of evidence is there.
In the context of vaccines,
I have looked at the impact
of Liberty and priority value.
So extending some work,
borrowing some work
from Jonathan Hyatt and
looking at it in the context
of vaccine decisions
whether they are moral decisions or not.
It turns out a lot of these
decisions are moral decisions.
And some of these, and
I've been looking at
specifically at liberty
and purity for awhile.
And because of these authoritarian strains
that have have become more
prominent in other fields as well
in terms of pushing back against
other Public Health interventions,
we are seeing some of that
work is newly relevant
in this particular context.
So I will wrap up by
saying that moving forward,
there are a lot of things
that concern us Public health types.
Governance is at the top of it.
But also, based on the
composition of the courts,
one of the things that makes
me nervous is the foundation
of a lot of public health law is
this decision that was done around
smallpox mandatory vaccination,
Jacobson versus Massachusetts.
And that sort of explicated
the police powers of the States
in the modern era or
relatively modern era.
The decision was of the progressive era
at the turn of the 20th century.
And that decision has
spawned a lot of thinking,
a lot of mainstream, both
legislation and regulation.
With the new composition of the court,
I'm not sure that we can take
those kinds of interventions
for granted, et cetera.
And so, you know, part of my
work has been on the using
behaviorally designed legislation
as a public health intervention.
And so there are certain things
that we took for granted.
I don't think we can take it for granted.
So I'll stop here and I'm sure
we will have the opportunity
to discuss several things.
And just to reassure everyone,
this is not a revenge.
I'm just great crashing
because you're a fun lot.
- All right, thank you very much Saad Omer
and thank you to all the panelists.
So we have a lot of questions
coming in from the audience.
I just wanted to remind everyone
that when we conclude the panel discussion
in about 10 minutes or
so, looking at the clock,
I'll start with some of the
questions that are being sent in
to the question and answer function.
And some of the questions are...
The questions I've been
trying to read them
while also paying
attention to my colleagues
and the questions are outstanding
and some of them are kind of long.
So I'm doing my best to sort of remember
and balance all of this
so good luck to me.
For now, let me just start
with just a couple of questions
and then we'll go to question and answer.
So my first question to the panel is
there's a difference of
opinion on the panel.
Maybe people noticed that
there was a little bit
of a difference of opinion regarding
how concerning the post-election
period ought to be.
I think if I remember correctly,
Isabella, I believe called
today's slow motion coup d'etat.
And I believe David referred to it as
the menace has diminished
and we're now kind of
getting back to normal.
We've gotten rid of Trump on
the one hand and that's what
the Democrats were concerned about
and the election was not
a resounding blue wave
which was what the
Republicans are worried about.
So kind of the temperature has gone down
and we're now entering
a period of more calm
and more normality, I guess.
I don't have his exact words.
So Isabella and David and anyone else who
wants to enter into the conversation here,
David, why aren't you more worried?
And Isabella, could you then respond
to what David has to say about
why he's not more worried
by the things that are
clearly worrying you?
And if anyone else wants
to jump in, of course
feel free to do so once Isabella and David
have had a moment to
exchange their views on this.
(mumbles)
- I think that
in order to contest in
an election successfully,
you need to have some costs to do it,
some empirical costs to do it
like the very close
vote in Florida in 2000.
And that difficulty carried
all the way to the courts
but it was a 600 vote or
something like that difficulty.
They had to see what went on
and they had to look and
fight about what went on.
Nothing like that is happening this year.
They're just telling stories.
Trump people are just telling
stories, that's about it.
- Yeah, so I agree with
Professor Mayhew that
clearly this election
went surprising well
given what was anticipated
and there was no post electoral violence,
the sort of very little fraud,
very little irregularities.
So all this industry worry
about a democratic erosion that
has in a way been proven wrong.
My comments referred more to the...
I linked this sort of right up period more
to the sort of regular intact
in a way any conflict that
is happening sort of now.
So in a way where I come in
or where sort of where my worry comes in
is more having survived.
And again, thinking about
the effort to legitimize.
of course, President Biden is
gonna be our next president.
Okay, but still, if you
look at the service today,
30% or more of voters
still, rightly believe
that this is not a legitimate president.
Because kind of his whole
strategies that have been
sort of that Trump has
used during the campaign
about sort of invoking fraud
have resonated with some voters.
So the concern here is more about
shrugging off this illegitimacy
kind of image in a way.
And sort of, again if we look at sort of
the book by Nancy Bermeo (mumbles)
everything you know and
compare it to politics, I mean
and I don't like to use this
comparison, Weimar Germany.
But in Weimar Germany,
the problem was that
a significant part of the
population never thought
that democracy was legitimate
and that sort of it was never possible
for the democratic kind of group
in the society at that
time to kind of shrug off
that sort of red image.
So this is a very risky strategy.
One sort of writes that
this is on the agenda
and one sort of ratified about this
and the answer sort read
based on what we noticed
is sometimes it's just not
possible and it doesn't end well.
So I think we are commenting
on different parts
of the sort of the election.
And through right the
distance sort of like
what's going to happen
sort of looking forward.
Instead of kind of when they
settle with these voters.
So I think this is where
the disagreement is.
(mumbles)
- David, do you have a response?
Would you like just to
give a response to that
and then if anyone else wants to comment?
- Yes, a little bit.
It's unsettling when you
get a fair proportion
or don't think an election was legitimate.
It's unsettling, it's happened
rarely in American history.
It happened last time.
You probably get more
than 30% after last time
we'll say the election
outcome was not legitimate
but we've gone past it.
I hope now that the fever going down
that all of us will go away.
I don't think our comparisons of
Weimar and is collapsed
make any sense at all.
They've kind of made it
go down to zero in 1931.
The parliament had a majority of parties
who are anti-democratic
and what they profess.
there's nothing like those
things going on in the US today.
- Okay, I have a feeling
this could back and forth
for some time.
So I'm gonna move on to another question
or another comment if there is one.
If not, we'll move to another question.
Seeing no comment, let
me ask Saad a question,
a COVID question.
Saad, you mentioned I think the sad facts
of the US's performance metrics
that they're very poor on COVID.
So we have two more months
until it looks like,
I guess that according to this panel,
Joe Biden will be the president.
So let's just stipulate that's the case.
So Joe Biden's gonna be the new president
but what can Joe Biden do now?
Are we waiting two months?
If you were on Joe Biden side,
what would you do tomorrow
to address the pandemic?
- Well, thank God I'm not Joe Biden.
But in terms of what can be
done and what should be done,
both on the domestic front
and on the global front
because there is an
opportunity that will be lost
if you're not at the table for
in the next two, three months
and I'll come to that in a second.
But domestically, we need to have
and I can go on and on
for the whole response
but I'll focus on vaccines for now.
First of all, the idea is to
have a national communication
and education campaign that's
one thing which is based,
which has three goals.
One, that it should be at scale.
So one thing in Public
Health which I call pilotisis
is we keep on doing
successful pilots and not,
it's almost a disease
that we don't scale up
to national level impact.
So avoid the temptation of
doing things here and there,
be ready for a national
level campaign, large scale.
It should focus on trust.
It should also engage communities.
And the first and the
last one is not at odds.
They are ways to engage
communities at scale
if you have a template.
Community organization is done at scale
for all sorts of things
and move water mobilization is one example
but it's not the only example.
So these should be the goals
and it should be science-based.
We should be ready for now.
They should get ready now
for that kind of a campaign.
But they should decide
on the fate of operation
watch speed from now
and send it back to the agencies perhaps
or have a more sort of
career folks involvement.
By the way, it already
has a pretty substantial
Korean involvement and
even the outside person
who co-leads this is
it's fairly mainstream.
And actually, if there is a counterfactual
to things not being handled by Jared,
it's operation watch speed.
Other than the name it has produced,
it is bringing together the agencies,
public health agencies and
other government agencies,
NIH, BARDA, FDA, CDC,
around an umbrella, have a coordination
by people who know what
they are talking about.
And look, it has been...
Yes, the naming could have
been different, et cetera.
They could have paid more
attention to communication.
But in terms of developing a vaccine,
it's been a reasonable success
but they need to decide on
that, what happens afterwards?
How did they mount a national response,
not just a federal response?
So engagement and the way it can happen is
engage non-government or
professional associations
from now like the
Association of State and
Territorial Health Officers
that's out there.
There's nothing stopping a campaign
from engaging with them directly.
The Association of Immunization
Managers is out there.
Engagement of companies,
the Infectious Disease Society of America,
the American Medical Association.
All of that, you don't have
to run the shadow government
for two months but you can get ready
for these kinds of
things when for January.
- Great.
Thanks a lot Saad.
And then I'd like to
ask Christina and Jacob.
So David laid out a scenario
where very little of what you might call
the progressive agenda becomes law
in a Biden administration.
Christina, you're an
expert on appointments,
the bureaucracy.
Can you tell us how that might
work under divided government
or especially if the Republicans
remain in control of the Senate.
And then after Jacob, if
you could say a word about
whether you concur with David regarding,
I guess it's H.R. 1 and all
of its political reforms
as well as all of the legislative reforms.
Do you concur with David
regarding what is likely to transpire
in terms of the Democrats political reform
and legislative agenda?
So Christina and then
Jacob and then after that,
I think we'll open it up to
questions from our audience.
So I'm gonna be going afterward
right to the Q and A function, thank you.
- Well, great.
So first of all, I think
David recognizing that
the likelihood of legislation
being stymied in Congress
is pretty high, particularly
given the small margins.
And so really it's gonna be
administrative policy making
that's going to be the way forward.
And even in a situation
where you have a Senate say,
Georgia doesn't end up attorning
both of its special
elections for the Democrats,
but instead the Republicans hold them.
The Federal Vacancies Reform Act
allows for a considerable amount
of time after inauguration
for acting appointees to serve.
And we've already seen
that the public really
doesn't have a huge issue
with the major managements
of the federal government
being individuals
who don't have Senate confirmation.
If they had had that, was
it peppered across the news?
You would imagine there
being some type of pushback
against Trump and there just hasn't been
from his Republican base or really
from much of the democratic base
outside of the really controversial
ones like Chad Wolfson,
like the newest, a shuffle
at the department of defense.
But the federal, the
FCRA allows for 300 days
for an acting appointee to
serve after inauguration
and then an additional
210 days if Senate nominee
is submitted and not confirmed.
And then another 210 days after that.
So if you're keeping track at home,
that's nearly 720 days
of interim appointees, and that
almost gets us to midterms.
So there's gonna be a lot of places
for administrative making to be led
by the Biden administration.
It just won't be led by
the Biden administration
with the Senate's consent
which that in and of itself
we can have a whole other
conversation about it.
- Yeah, so very quickly.
I mean, first of all, David
was my dissertation advisor.
And I think
there's the Reagan's rule was
thou shall not criticize
a fellow Republican.
Thou shall not criticize
their dissertation advisor
is pretty high up there.
But I'll say that I haven't
put my concerns about
democratic backsliding
into my file cabinet.
I think it's very much
front and center still.
And my greatest regret about
the election honestly is that
there looks to be very limited scope
to pursue some sensible
democratic political reforms,
small d democratic political reforms.
And to me, everyone knows
what the big ones should be.
It's not court packing.
It's not Puerto Rico and DC statehood
though, I would be
supportive of the latter.
It's making sure that every
American has the right to vote
and that politicians are prevented
or at least have reduced capacity
to choose their voters rather
than voters choosing them
through extreme partisan gerrymandering.
So the prospects for
those things are dismal.
But I think, one thing that
Democrats should recognize is
that fighting the good fight
is sometimes good politics too.
I would push for these
and I think that's why
Senate control is crucial.
Is Joe Manchin gonna prevent?
I mean, my public option
does not look to have
the greatest prospects
in Joe Manchin's Senate.
But if the agenda is
controlled by Democrats
because they have the Senate majority
then there will be the prospect
for bringing these things
before the Congress,
before the American people
and having that debate which
I think we should have.
On broader policy changes, Saad is right.
We're living in an
alternative reality show
where a significant chunk
of the political class
is pretending that what's happening,
that what Donald Trump
believes is happening
is or at least are not pushing back
against his belief about what's happening.
And in the real world, people are dying
and they're dying because
we haven't had an effective policy
and we're not gonna have
an effect affective policy.
We're not gonna be able to
formulate an effective policy
if we can't have a transition
that moves forward smoothly
or if we don't have any capacity
for the incoming president to govern.
Now, I'm hopeful that at least
on the really fundamental things
that seem to need to happen
then that that will happen.
But I thought Saad put it really well that
we have seen some pockets
of competence in operation work speed.
I agree on the name.
I think we can call the rest of
the COVID policies
operation death star maybe.
But anyway let me just end by saying that
I think that the biggest
silver lining in this
and it was mentioned in the Q and A
is that we are gonna turn the corner
and we're more likely to do so faster
if we have some effective leadership.
And so this may not be a
typical midterm, right?
It's a, not gonna feature a
lot of polarizing legislation.
And it's b, gonna feature
a significant reversal
in our situation which may
well make it more likely
that the president elect
will be in a better position
than he might be otherwise in a few years.
- Thank you very much, Jacob.
Okay, so I'm gonna go...
Some of the questions have been answered
during the comments on the panel.
Others are less so I'm gonna try
and kind of weave my way
through the questions.
So here's a question.
I guess, I'll direct this first at David
and then at the anyone else
who wants to participate.
Question is do you think there'll be
any legislative common ground
between president Joe Biden
and a Republican Congress?
This is in the event
that the Republicans get one
of the two Georgia seats.
You mentioned all the things
that weren't gonna happen.
Can you say a bit about what
you think might might happen?
And then of course anyone
else who wants to comment,
I would be welcome.
- Well, I'm saying there
always has to be common ground
ultimately on budgeting.
Budgeting has to take place every year
and budgeting is commonly
a consequence of things
that both parties tuck
into a large instrument
so that they get common
ground in that sense.
That's very important.
A lot of policy making
is done at the budgets.
Another thing is that, I think
Biden, as everybody says,
Biden is very good with going
with people on Capitol Hill.
And probably, I'm not sure
about this with McConnell.
That is the...
They're better vibrations there
than way you've seen him seven years
between the Senate leader or
the president probably anyway.
I think there are some policy
areas in which there might be
some fruitful cooperation between them,
maybe infrastructure is one.
Everybody talks about infrastructure
but nobody's got a plan
and certainly no body
got a plan to pay for it.
But it is an area in which
nonpartisan activity can happen.
So if they put their heads to it,
it's possible they could
do something on that front.
- I can't actually see as well
because I've got this question
and answer screen that's sitting in front
of some of the panelists.
I don't see anyone else
wanting to comment on this.
So we'll move on to the next question.
So the next question is one about
the kind of the generally
political coalitions
the question or asks about exit poll data
regarding independent voters.
I'll just read the question
and I'll ask you to comment on this issue
and as well as its
implications more generally.
But here's the question.
I've seen exit poll data
that independent voters
generally perceive
Democrats to care more about
social issues and Republicans
to care more about
economic issues in 2020.
And the conventional wisdom is that
voters tend to prioritize economic issues
over social foreign policy
issues at the ballot box.
I've also seen some high
profile left-leaning pundits
believe this explains Democrats sliding
among non-college
educated Latinos in 2020.
Is this exit poll data
considered high quality?
If so, is this something
the democratic party
should aim to correct?
So if anyone wants to address
that particular aspect
of the political coalitions,
that would be great.
If you would like to also
address more generally
the question of what might we...
I don't know that we do have
really reliable exit poll data
for a variety of reasons
but we do have some.
We're beginning to see
what data from precincts
and from counties and house districts
and things like that that
does seem to indicate
some shifts in the Republic
and voting coalition.
Would anybody like to
comment on this question
also informed by other data about
how the Republican voting coalition
might've changed over
the last several years
and as evidenced in this election?
- Well, excuse me okay.
- Yeah, please fire away.
- It's a resemblance on the map.
I mean you go to South
Texas and South Florida,
you can see on the map
that the Democrats did
worse than they expected
or usually have done
among Hispanic voters.
That is to say that most Hispanic voters
don't still vote democratic, they do.
But doesn't the last at the edge,
you see it on the map.
It's not just exit polls.
- Right, any comments about the...
So we're gonna actually
have a whole panel on
this sort of these voting
behavior questions in two weeks.
And we have some amazing
people who are experts
on that nitty gritty of
these sorts of questions.
That doesn't mean that
others don't have opinions
that they might wanna share
but I'm looking at the panel.
- I wanna add.
I am not an election expert.
And Isabella, did you wanna jump in?
I see your mute is off now.
Okay, so I'm not an election expert.
I assume I'm really looking
forward to that panel.
I would just say three quick things.
One is, given how far the
polls were off in general
and we'll surely have a discussion of that
at the next panel,
I would be careful about
exit polls right now.
Second, it's not gonna come to this.
it's not gonna be the case
that we're gonna have seen
a fundamental shift in the
bases of these parties, right?
We're talking about enormous continuity.
And indeed, I mean, I really do think that
the central fact of American
politics today that we saw
is both sides were able
to get lots of people out
but the persuasion was operating
on a very small segment
of the electorate, right?
And the degree to which
there is a chunk of,
this is something Isabella
noted and compared.
The degree to which, despite
an enormous catastrophe,
electoral alignment seem fairly stable
is itself a very remarkable feature.
And the third thing I would say is that,
wherever it came from,
Joe Biden put together
a pretty effective map
and it looks especially
remarkable when you compare it
with the rest of the democratic
electoral candidates,
the rest of the candidates, right?
- Okay.
- That's why he's gonna be
the next president, right?
- Good, okay thank you very much.
Another question, it has
a self-deprecating part.
This might seem a terribly
uninformed question, okay?
It's actually, I think a good question.
And Isabella, you might have
something to add to this
and others as well.
But why do we need to have
this transition system
when other countries have
the newly elected head
of state taking office the very next day?
What's up with that, this transitions,
this two and a half, whatever
month transition system.
it is a little strange, isn't it?
Isabella, could you just put
this in comparative perspective
and then David, anyone
else who wants to comment
that would be great.
- I'm Looking for (mumbles).
I'm not an expert on American politics.
It seems to me, isn't this a
legacy of the electoral college
and the fact that you
had this institutions
where they had to gather
together and sort of come.
So it's just this historical
accident I think kind of
that is connected to the electoral college
that sort of creates
this kind of lag that we-
- Yes, so I think
Isabella's frozen not me.
Is Isabella frozen?
Okay, it's usually me.
- I'm sure Christina or David
can tell the difference.
- David, do you wanna jump in
and then Isabella can catch
up or Christina comments.
- (mumbles) and you know what
has happened to these efforts
historically, because probably we're not
at the only moment in history
when we are kind of agonizing
for having to wait for two months.
- There was the great depression.
Well, that was a big one
with Franklin Roosevelt.
But David, do you have a
comment you'd like to make?
- That was a good question.
Maybe we're not hitting on transitions.
It's easy to see why it's there
and why it should be there.
There's just a hangover
from the 18th century.
Rigidly they had a longer transition.
It was from early November to early March
and then they collapse it a bit
but they collapsed two
months delay as a resident.
Maybe there's no good reason for it.
Maybe there's something
to do with presidencies.
But I don't know that,
presidency is general.
I just don't know.
- Christina, is there
something you'd like to add?
- Yeah, I think also a lot of
it in parliamentary systems
you have shadow governments.
You have minority governments
that have their own shadow
ministers that are involved
in the process of
administrating the government.
Whereas in our system, we don't have that.
We don't have a democratic
or Republic opposite party
secretary of state
or an opposite party,
secretary of transportation.
And so the transitions actually start well
before the election.
The transition start is weekly mandated
to start six months before the election
and that's when the
individuals who are currently
in the administration they get together.
They find their leaders
within each department
who would lead the transition
and they create documents.
They create transition landing manuals
in order to inform the new administration,
not only of the status quo
of policies and regulations
that are still in play
or still being processed
but also just who people are
and where the positions are.
There's a plum book as it's
called is a 600 page document
book that's published every four years
giving way to the all of the appointments
that need to be made by
a new administration.
And because of the way that we've set up
our federal appointment system,
the new administration has to come in
and fill all of those spots.
And so not only figure
out what spots there are
and who is filling them but then also
what kind of world those
people are living in
and whether or not they even
want those people to leave.
Oftentimes we have a lot
of holdovers that hang on
after the transition because
it takes so much time
to get your feet under you.
- It looks like one of
those holdovers this year
will be Donald J. Trump.
- it's actually an interesting thing.
I guess because it's not a party system.
The how would the shadow,
the shadow cabinet workers,
because the shadow cabinet
is associated with a political party.
We don't know who the
nominee is until the summer.
They would have to then put
together the shadow cabinet.
I would imagine unless that's something
the voters expect and demand,
people have all sorts of
reasons not to want to
have to put forth the shadow cabinet
if unless they were compelled
to by public pressure
because the folks are then
vulnerable to all of the.
I remember I worked on
a political campaign
where people were suggesting
the presidential candidate
named 10 people who might be
the possible vice presidential nominees
and we were petrified that
they would both be ridiculous
and also open each of those
people up to a withering attack.
If they were named,
they would have a target put on their back
once their name was names were released.
Okay, let's get a few more questions in.
I'm gonna go to the bottom here
and let's see what we've got.
Let's see.
Okay, here's a question.
Professor Kinane, are there cabinet seats
that are critical to fill quickly?
So while I'm looking
at the other questions,
what are the cabinet seats
that need to be filled right away?
- All of them.
- All of them, okay.
You care to elaborate?
- Certainly.
Typically, first of all,
there's the line of succession
is of course important to recognize
and oftentimes cabinet
positions are confirmed
kind of in order of where they
sit in the succession line
being Secretary of State first.
But we face as Saad has said,
we face a world of just epic
proportions of mortality
and morbidity that needs to
be addressed immediately.
So really you need a
department of Homeland security
and you need a department
of health and human services
on day minus two, right?
Like you need someone who is facilitating
and coordinating this
massive scale intervention
that needs to happen not
only for vaccinations
but also for the fact that you have
an entire disinformation
campaign to overcome.
You need to inform people
that their hospitals are at max capacity.
And what that means
for them, the fact that
just because you aren't experiencing
or don't believe that COVID
is a thing that happens
or a thing that will affect you
doesn't mean you won't at one point
potentially need to be in a hospital.
Like we should all stop driving our cars.
If there's no ICU beds in
case we get in a car accident,
we should, we should watch
out for all of the individuals
who have heart conditions
that won't seek healthcare
because either they can't
because hospitals are full
or because there are afraid
of the risk of catching COVID.
And so you have as Saad so nicely Put,
you have this need for an administration
that is not only working
but is on the ground.
And so interior is important.
It's always going to be important,
It might be less important
in terms of of dealing with
the situation at hand.
- Thank you very much, Christina.
Okay, so in our final
few moments together,
I just wanna ask the group,
maybe in the order of
appearance on the panel,
where do you go personally for information
in this time of great national upheaval
and political change?
Where do you seek out information
and what have you read recently,
a book or an article or two
that has informed the way
you think about politics
that you would recommend
to interested members
of our audience here?
What would be a really
interesting thing to read?
Like, I think Isabella
mentioned Nancy Romeo's work
and it's deep scholarship
that's also of relevance.
So what might you
recommend to our community?
So we'll just start with Jacob
and go in order of appearance.
- Yeah, so I would recommend
probably spending less time on Twitter
and more time talking to people.
But what I've found, I found that,
it's gonna be predictable,
but I've found it really helpful to have
the very regular updates
that the times is providing
as well as the long form journalism
that's been appearing in the Atlantic
I think has been excellent
during this crisis.
Speaking of another long from journalist,
I would read Jane Mayer's wonderful piece
about Mitch McConnell that
appeared earlier this year.
We'll see how relevant it's gonna be.
And books that have really influenced me,
I've actually told a
number of people this and
I'm not sucking up to
my senior colleagues.
Jim Scott's against the grain
which is really a remarkable book.
A lot of it is about the way
pandemics have reshaped societies,
so I recommend it highly.
- Thank you, Jacob.
I forget who was second.
Was it Christine, Christine in it?
- Yeah. I agree with you, Jacob
about staying off of Twitter
although I do have to say and I think that
as not certainly one of the
armchair epidemiologists
that Saad railed against, I
definitely feel that getting
into epi Twitter made
me epically more aware
of the oncoming pandemic
back in February and March
then probably it would
have been elsewhere.
So I must say that there is
an incredible information
campaign that is happening
by epidemiologists to their
absolute credit on Twitter.
There's a lot of work that has been done
to accumulate data and
to accumulate knowledge
in really readable form.
So I agree with you that
Twitter is by and large bad
for your blood pressure, I think.
But for information that you might not
easily come in contact with,
I think getting into one
of those circles is great.
In terms of books, Will
Howell and Terry Moe's
newest book on the presidency
I found fascinating and
infuriating at the same time
mostly because it's about
populist presidencies
and I think I would recommend that 100%.
- Great, thank you, Christina.
Isabella?
- Yeah, so I thank you for this question.
It's actually very thought-provoking.
And so for me,
I have been reading a lot of
historical books on pandemics
just trying to understand that.
And one that I would strongly recommend is
by a historian at UCLA,
his name is Peter Baldwin
and the book is called
"Contagion and the State"
and it is about sort
of historical responses
to health crisis.
So I would add that to the list
of sort of also Nancy
Bermejo, who is an author
I find sort of highly relevant today.
I mentioned about in the beginning.
- Thank you very much, Isabella.
David?
- I'll go to Jacobs already
mentioned Jim Scottsbluff
and I agree with that in
a book something like that
which I've recommended to you, by the way.
It's by Walter Scheidel.
He's an Economic History
professor at Stanford.
I can't remember the exact title
but I think it has equality
in it or inequality.
It also has violence in it.
It's about equality and inequality
during the last 3000 years.
- Great, thank you, David.
And Saad?
- So I would recommend and
I've been reading a bit
not as much as I would have liked to
because of some of the
other stuff that have to do.
But I would say very early on,
I went back to Camus "The Plague."
It's a classic and it's, you know,
I'm not exaggerating but it
almost gave me goosebumps
in terms of earlier on.
Like how the more things change,
the more they remain the same, et cetera.
So I would suggest going back to that.
the Atlantic has had
some of the best writing
on the pandemic, I absolutely agree.
Especially Ed Yong's on it.
It's very thoughtful.
It's not at all superficial.
And the last thing I would say,
if you care about institutions,
read the long form article
by Pro-Publica on CDCs
brawl on this.
Take the time, read it
and then read it again
because there are lessons for
other institutions as well.
So I'll pause here.
- Thank you very much.
Thank you all so much for taking the time
to join together this evening
for this conversation.
I hope everyone in the
audience appreciated it
as much as I did.
I'd like to once again advertise,
we're gonna do this again
a slightly different way.
In two weeks, we're having a session.
What did voters do and why did they do it?
Another panel discussion
sponsored by ISPS.
With that, I'd like to,
again, thank the panelists.
Thank Pam Greene and Lamar Pier
who worked to set up today's event
and thank you all for joining us.
I look forward to seeing
you at future ISPS events.
- Thank you, Alan.
- Thank you.
- Of course.
Bye bye everyone.
- Bye bye.